hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion this is Abraham Shafi he created
a simple app that helps users meet their
friends in real life his app called in
real life or IRL for short was valued at
1.5 billion dollars
it boasted 20 million users he'd be
forgiven for thinking that this is the
next Facebook or Instagram in the making
but there was a dirty secret hidden
behind the success
in April of 2023 Shafi came under
investigation for alleged misconduct a
few weeks later an investigation
discovered that the app had a very big
problem 95 of its users weren't real at
all that's right the investors were
scammed
it's insane but there's some questions
here how did this billion dollar Scandal
unfold and what lessons can be learned
Fusion TV
son of an Egyptian immigrant IRL CEO
Abraham sheffy was inspired by his
father's resilience
in the 1980s his father fled war-torn
Cairo and made a home in the United
States
sheffy wanted to prove himself so he set
out to do so
in 2009 he attended UC Berkeley taking
classes in anthropology business and
computer engineering in 2012 he would
drop out to co-found a social recruiting
platform it was called gettalent.com
after selling the company shafi's next
project would be called gather it had a
similar Vision to IRL but even at these
early stages there was problems massive
problems gather would come under
scrutiny for spamming users contact
lists this was an attempt to boost
growth frustrated users took to Reddit
to air their grievances quote First it
asked for access to your contacts then
uploads every contact from your phone to
their systems where they can send out
spare messages to get them to join rinse
and repeat got to wonder why you can't
even launch the app without first giving
it access to your contacts why does it
want that so bad
some of these posts got the attention of
Shafi himself he responded with long
messages to defend his platform but a
key quote was quote we didn't handle
growing correctly but took these lessons
to heart and are committed to not
repeating the same mistakes this didn't
go well users pointed out that what he
was doing was illegal plain and simple
eventually The Gather app was scrapped
amidst a steaming pile of controversy
but this didn't matter because Shafi had
something bigger in store
sheffy would realize that gen Z doesn't
use Facebook so why not take the event
planning section of Facebook mix it with
a group chat function and call it a day
and with that idea in 2017 IRL was born
the vision was to help its users group
message and plan meetups in real life
because according to IRL the best way to
solve society's loneliness epidemic is
with another mobile app
the platform was designed exclusively
for connecting people through shared
interests when sheffy showed investors
they were impressed
firm floodgates who were early investors
in Twitter and the founders fund who
previously invested in Airbnb Facebook
and Lyft were Keen to give Shafi money
in June of 2021 another 170 million
dollars was raised and this was led by
SoftBank if the name SoftBank sounds
familiar to you there's a good reason
why they've made headlines in recent
years for just having one bad investment
after another this includes wework and
FTX
[Music]
so while from an investment perspective
IRL had all the potential of being the
new Golden Child in a bid to gain app
users IRL just like its predecessor
gather would also engage in spamming
this included sending out unsolicited
text messages to the contacts of users
they were called nominations on
downloading the app users had to give
the app access to their address book
from there they were asked a series of
multiple choice questions with four of
the user's contacts as possible answers
if those friends weren't on the app the
app would send them a text message to
let them know that they've been
nominated but it wouldn't tell you who
nominated you of course in order to find
that out you would have to create an IRL
account unsurprisingly everyone hated it
in 2020 during the pandemic in-person
events across the globe were canceled
the company quickly pivoted to Virtual
events this included integration with
platforms such as twitch YouTube and
Tick Tock a year later following more
investment IRL reached unicorn status as
it was now valued over 1 billion dollars
at this point IRL boasted 20 million
users mostly gen Z middle American
teenagers
it seemed like this app was going to be
the next hottest thing but things were
about to get messy and Fast shafi's
Company was about to get exposed
Nicholas Grant a software engineer
joined IRL in January of 2022. two
concerned co-workers would confine and
Grant that something odd was going on
behind the scenes
within a few weeks he would come to
learn that many of the photographs
shared on IRL were stock images not
user-generated photos he also became
aware of the discrepancies between the
statistics on Google Play and irl's
publicly stated figures
things got weirder still on one day an
internal dashboard showed that almost
all user activity within the United
States disappeared suspiciously at the
same time there was a large spike in
Latin American traffic with millions of
users suddenly appearing in Argentina
Brazil and Mexico
countries which only had a few hundred
thousand users just a moment ago Grant
verified that this traffic was authentic
he also confirmed that there were no
marketing campaigns targeting Latin
America there was only one logical
conclusion the vast majority of users on
this platform were Bots
after sharing his findings with the
managers at IRL Grant discovered that
his role at the company suspiciously had
been changed and changed in such a way
that the access that he had to internal
data sources had been revoked
and then came the memo from the CEO
himself Abraham Shafi it was addressed
to the 100th staff of IRL a quarter of
the staff will be made redundant among
those who did make the cut of course was
Nicholas Grant
following Grant's findings in December
of 2022 the SEC launched an inquiry into
IRL the company was accused of
misleading investors when presenting
their metrics in turn this led to Shafi
being suspended in April of 2023 and
this was on allegations of misconduct
in June of 2023 an investigation by
irl's board of directors revealed that a
staggering 95 percent of those 20
million users were automated the actual
users on the app was closer to 1 million
as a result of the investigations into
fake user accounts IRL was dissolved
with immediate effect assets were moved
into a liquidating trust and the
Investor's Capital was returned the IRL
app was formally shut down on June 27
so what happens now for the one to two
million real users they're going to have
to find another way to meet each other
in real life as for the SEC inquiry it's
still ongoing so we're going to have to
wait for the legal cases to see what
exact charges Shafi and the rest of
management are going to face all will
have to be proven in a court of law
on July 5th Chaffee took to LinkedIn to
make a public statement in it he claims
that the report's findings were quote
flat wrong and that he quote continued
to have confidence in their metrics
in an interview he would explain that
the differences between his figures and
the external estimates come down to the
majority of the user base being
teenagers he says that for privacy
reasons it's harder to track these users
data but based on other things that he
said about the matter it's hard to trust
him for example sheffy would state that
the external estimates didn't include
web users he claims that this made up 20
of irl's usage however other external
estimates don't agree the monthly web
visits would be about 270 000 far short
of the millions is claiming
so at this point he's denying the
allegations made against him but it's
not looking good
isn't this all sounding familiar though
the downfall of IRL and its founder
Shafi is the latest in a string of
high-profile cases involving defrauding
investors the most recent of which we
just covered it was the infamous case of
Charlie Javis she's being accused of
defrauding JP Morgan out of 175 million
dollars and she did a very similar thing
the real user base of her platform was
three hundred thousand but in the sale
she claimed that those four million
users
so why do all this
in the world of startups there can be a
culture of Faking it till you make it an
app with a large number of users could
mean hundreds of millions of dollars in
investment but why do they risk it
especially if they know the consequences
could be a lifetime in jail well one it
really is a lifetime and two it could
just be an intense pressure to deliver
once investors are on board they want to
see growth genuinely growing an active
user base is incredibly difficult some
entrepreneurs may try to take shortcuts
but the one question that we all want to
know the answer to Is how do these guys
think that they can just get away with
faking numbers eventually people are
going to find out maybe the fame and
fortune is just too alluring
so that is the story of IRL the social
media app that promised to help friends
meet in real life although it turned out
that there were very few real-life users
we've got quite the collection of
colorful characters now on Cold Fusion
SPF Charlie Javas Elizabeth Holmes
Trevor Milton dokwon and now Abraham
Shafi
something tells me that this isn't going
to be the last high-profile fraud case
that we see
now that the days of low interest rates
and free-flowing cash may be behind us
investors are doing more due diligence
perhaps the times are fake it till you
make May well and truly be over and
that's a good thing in my book I'll
leave you with a question think that
there's more fraud happening or are we
just getting better at identifying if
more fraud is happening why do you think
that is
feel free to discuss in the comments
section below
so anyway thanks for watching if you
want to see stuff on science technology
or business take a look around cold
fusion alright so my name is the gogo
and you've been watching cold fusion and
I'll catch you again soon for the next
episode cheers guys
operation
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]